una delle cose che dico sempre quando mi
devo presentare sono veneziana e io
credo che questo sia un fatto che in un
certo senso caratterizza tutti i
veneziani perché tutti i veneziani
sentono il bisogno di dire a gran voce
che provengono da una città diversa da
tutte le altre
perché perché succede perché purtroppo
sono effettivamente sempre più rari e ma
forse ancora di più perché
Venezia in un certo senso ti entra
dentro ti riempie tu sei un vaso e lei è
l'acqua che idrata letteralmente i tuoi
pensieri e quando cresci ehm
fisicamente o ancora di più
intellettualmente a Venezia camminando
per le sue calli attraversando i suoi
campi alzandoti abbassandoti al ritmo
delle Acque alte non hai scelta sei
legato per sempre a questa città al alla
sua forma alla sua architettura al dolce
peso della sua storia ma soprattutto sei
sei legato al al suo modo di insegnarti
a interpretare i problemi e i limiti di
questa città ne ha di limiti però tu
impari a vedere questi limiti non come
dei punti di debolezza Ma come dei punti
di forza e
infatti Venezia per la sua conformazione
fisica particolarissima naturale e
artificiale allo stesso tempo e per la
sua incredibile eh incredibile eh
particolarità architettonica e
costruttiva
non è soltanto una gita bellissima
Venezia in un certo senso rappresenta
una direzione una rotta una una
possibilità verso una vita più
sostenibile e a misura d'uomo e mi rendo
conto che questo possa non essere
l'immaginario comune la maggior parte
delle persone pensando a Venezia Pensa
una città estremamente complessa
estremamente scomoda
piena di barriera architettoniche di
vincoli edilizi
costretta ad una mobilità lenta e quindi
è inefficiente Ma è davvero così
da sempre gli architetti
nel cercare di Trasformare lo spazio per
renderlo a misura d'uomo si sono
interrogati su come fare e la misura
utilizzata in principio per rendere lo
spazio adatto alla vita è letteralmente
quella umana pensiamo banalmente al
piede come unità di misura che è
utilizzata ancora ad oggi e
questo ovviamente è successo anche a
Venezia quando si è trattato di
costruire Venezia e
le misure è stata pensata è stata quella
umana e anche in questo caso e oggi
forse ancora più che in un passato
recente Venezia si trova a racchiudere
al suo interno tutte quelle misure che
gli architetti innovatori e i mecenati
visionari cercano di disegnare di
teorizzare all'interno della città del
futuro
mobilità completamente pedonale servizi
raggiungibili nell'arco di 20 minuti a
piedi al massimo
servizi di collegamento pubblico urbano
interno alla città
valorizzazione della Dimensione sociale
e dell'interazione tra le persone
natura al centro e protagonista
sostenibilità e utilizzo di risorse
rinnovabili Ecco questi sono che vi ho
appena elencato sono i punti
fondamentali del programma di design che
per chi non la conoscesse è l'ultima
arrivata tra le i progetti di città
futuristiche ideali che forse vedremo
sorgere nei prossimi anni chi lo sa nel
deserto eh ripeto nel deserto
dell'Arabia Saudita
Se ci pensate bene Fate eccezione per la
sostenibilità e l'utilizzo di risorse
rinnovabili che è effettivamente un work
in progress un po' per tutti tutti gli
altri punti della checklist Venezia era
già a Venezia bisogna utilizzare il
proprio corpo per muoversi per camminare
e
questo può essere un esercizio forse
scomodo però è estremamente salutare a
Venezia tutti i servizi sono
raggiungibili nell'arco di 20 minuti o
poco più perché Venezia è estremamente
piccola e a Venezia il collegamento
interno alla città come Servizio
Pubblico forse non tutti lo sanno ma è
arrivato addirittura con 10 anni
d'anticipo rispetto a quanto è successo
nella terraferma Eh i primi vaporini o
vaporetti come li chiamiamo oggi
risalgono addirittura al 1891 con 10
anni di anticipo rispetto a quello che è
successo con i trampoli elettrici di
terraferma e questo secondo me il fatto
che ci mostra come Venezia sia stata in
grado e sia ancora oggi in grado di
adattarsi a quella che quelle che sono
le nuove esigenze sotto la spinta
ovviamente del Progresso tecnico e a
Venezia l'interazione sociale è
garantita la mobilità lenta lo aiuta
bisogna camminare e camminando ci si
incontra si parla ci si scambia idee e a
Venezia la la Scusatemi Io sto perdendo
il microfono
e comunque io farò una cosa Permettetemi
ma
Eccomi Allora come dicevo a Venezia
l'interazione sociale è garantita e
proprio dalla mobilità lenta e a Venezia
la natura è protagonista come ci ha
detto Jane la vita della della città
dipende dalla vitalità della laguna luna
non può esistere senza l'altra e proprio
in questo senso la sinergia tra uomo e
natura deve essere portata ai massimi
livelli possibili
e proprio proprio questo fatto
ci mostra come Venezia appunto abbia
tanti punti in comune con The Line però
ce n'è uno
ce n'è uno che Venezia non ha per
fortuna in comune condeline ossia
Venezia è un passato Venezia non è una
città costruita di punto in bianco
Venezia è un palinsesto una una
tela su cui artisti architetti o
semplicemente esseri umani hanno
sovrapposto la loro tecnica e la loro
esperienza e questa esperienza di vita è
leggibile è leggibile su ogni pietra su
ogni laterizio dell'architettura della
città Ecco perché penso che gli
architetti abbiano un ruolo molto
importante che è quello di valorizzare e
tutelare questo patrimonio edilizio
storico e di trasferi pantalone il
valore trasferire il valore di questa
sovrapposizione di vite e di esperienze
a chi nella nell'architettura storica
piuttosto vede un limite un limite dato
dalla dal fatto di non poter sempre
raggiungere tutti quegli
standard di comodità ed efficienza
e che quindi la fanno la fanno sembrare
meno efficiente appunto di una città
completamente nuova e Ecco perché
accanto a questo la sostenibilità
economica sociale e ambientale Io penso
esiste anche un altro tipo di
sostenibilità una sostenibilità che
provo a definire come umanistica perché
Venezia proprio per la sua conformazione
fisica può diventare un esempio di
questa di questa sostenibilità perché è
nata in un in un momento
in un momento in cui la la storia e
in cui il pensiero umano era al centro
della della
Scusatemi ho perso il filo del discorso
volevo dire che Venezia può diventare un
esempio di questa di questa
sostenibilità
umanistica perché
la sua conformazione fisica
particolarissima la preservata dalla
maggior parte dei cambiamenti
strutturali che invece hanno
caratterizzato le più note città del
nostro mondo e quindi come una sorta di
Pompei vivente ha permesso ai suoi
cittadini di continuare a vivere in un
ambiente che è nato in un momento in cui
l'uomo era il centro del pensiero non la
macchina e quindi era il centro
dell'architettura dell'arte
dell'Economia e della politica e ed è
per questo che credo che Venezia ci sia
lanciando un messaggio ad almeno molto
forte
la l'ambizione del dell'uomo del futuro
nel cercare di migliorare la sua
condizione umana non è quella di
rivoluzionare completamente il proprio
modo di vivere in virtù dell'efficienza
e delle della comodità
l'ambizione dell'uomo del futuro
Piuttosto è quella di riuscire a vivere
secondo la misura umana e la misura
umana non è l'efficienza che invece è
proprio della macchina la misura umana e
la capacità di esprimere se stesso
all'interno di uno spazio e Venezia può
permettere di esprimersi al massimo
perché in un certo senso è estremamente
ergonomica nel senso letterale del
termine che è dato dall'Unione delle
parole greche ergon lavoro e non mostra
regola e quindi quando dico che Venezia
ergonomica Intendo dire che Venezia
consente di lavorare e quindi di vivere
secondo quelle regole che col passare
dei secoli sono entrata intimamente a
far parte dell'essenza dell'uomo quindi
il rispetto del contesto naturale Il
rispetto della anatomia del corpo e il
rispetto della Dimensione
culturale storica e sociale
e quindi la E quindi la la sostenibilità
che bisognerebbe ricercare in ogni città
del futuro è quella umanistica
e quello umanistica perché deve essere
una sostenibilità
tutta la vita una sostenibilità tutto
tondo che fonda le sue radici nella
dimensione storico adattiva dell'essere
umano e quindi Se cambiamo prospettiva e
usiamo quella Veneziana ci rendiamo
conto che Venezia non è scomoda Anzi
Venezia
continua a indicare a tutti gli
architetti del mondo e non solo La Rotta
per la progettazione di spazi realmente
a misura d'uomo